hey guys Greggy here and Johnny here so
I uploaded my reaction of Star Wars the
last Jedi I thought the trailer was
awesome mother'll urge on just showed up
hey Shmuel free-for-all went up today
this guy that's all hey you gotta watch
it you gotta watch it seriously got it
Humphry the last yet i trailer Star
Tours there last there is a few TV
there's a few people who were like
where's Jon so oh I'm here today we'll
show Jon this trail yeah that's a
thumbnail yeah nothing beats a thumbnail
offended Osgood's fan look like this
lead yes I'm so excited to watch it this
time you can try whoa whoa whoa our
quality is off what is that with the
quality tent John no we got to start
this again 720p format was not doing it
the times are like this your little time
you're still getting
a beautiful Alacoque head cool shot
this is Rancho yeah like so long
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
whoa
we know one shoe
[Music]
[Music]
make something new
John my third time watching this give me
your hand
oh yeah oh yeah you third die watching
this the thing is you really do have to
it's just such a cool trailer gonna be
yeah I mean that's a little wow that
really got me swept up in it you know
like yeah that's all this like isolated
in the dream like I'm on this rock
healing doula I'm actually just looking
forward to it but Rand Luke refuses yeah
because that opening shot what is going
on there she's like going through some
serious intense Jedi training
yeah well and I love the way this is all
shot I mean like you know behind Johnson
fans so like I'm super excited to see
what he brings the Star Wars universe
and he seems to shoot a little bit more
a wide frame wide frames and this I mean
this had a lot of like shadows and like
weird that moment of end where he's just
standing in the mouth of a cave and all
shadows except for that looks like it's
sweet I think it's going to be a
definitely a darker film I I keep
wondering what that shot of sin is out
of all the shots to show it then it's
doing his eyes closed it's an odd way to
cut a design the way the tree to go that
it's like all those ships are battling
and shooting and there's red smoke and
Finn just yeah I'm going to do this a
month sleep in that's how his special
power comes out as you get the less he
thinks the better even just like Ashby
is the action is ready the code gamer is
just you know the Han Solo this again
yeah if Han Solo went out on more
dangerous like dog fighting missions you
know
yes too bad for him and his ship gets
like blown up
yeah they shown the trailers yeah yeah
the first one he gets taken hostage
right away they've gone for most of the
movie and here it's like I now you might
not be able to do as much action again
here's how thin man is open I just want
to know where the story said you know
yeah I keep wondering with it just keeps
bugging me like why is Luke saying so I
read a con over there like it might be
beneath because we need to little Toros
in this and they're saying it's kind of
hot doggers your nice little Toros what
you're saying
be Luke's speaking sound like Mark
Hamill and showed Mark Hamill is very
happy is the opening shot kinda reminds
me it's like it's same effect of when
the the first Star Wars trailer for
force awakens came out where fin pops up
in frame yank on with jumpscared yeah
gotta like you because it look at first
it look like when I first time I thought
I was looking at planet and they did it
and her hands here oh we're a is having
an intense day yeah it's cool cuz it's
picking up exactly where's a lot phone
left off yeah that's probably what I'm
most excited but I mean like I like a
trailer like this to kind of just shows
you a lot of images and don't give you a
heap ton of like plot points and that's
not that were so good at that
yeah and it's not like they need to
entice us with them and the only reason
I'm curious about the plot of this movie
now is because force awakens wool is
very similar to a new hope and like this
trailer Chi had at least for me like an
even mix of like oh wow there's some new
[ __ ] in this trailer there's also some
classic Star Wars you had people
standing in front of hologram things and
like you know dogfights in space over
moons and some like that I'm very
intrigued but boo yeah all right guys
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell to get
notified every time one of our videos is
up jobs reasons the Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of blue
MIDI Blum house on the real rejects and
check out the free for all where I make
a cameo yeah you're here in the free for
all and then I have a little cameo with
John oh yeah I made two cameos and I'm a
little more than that